une polémique à montfermeil en région
parisienne pierre bernard le maire
divers droite de la cité en effet
transférer la charge des écoles à
l'inspection académique
l'objet du litige la présence d'une
quarantaine d'enfants immigrés dans
l'école contre son avis pierre bernard
évoque également la forte concentration
de cette population immigrée qui atteint
85% dans certaines cités nombreuses
condamnations de l'attitude du maire les
associations parlant même ce soir d'un
véritable appareil municipal philippe
pecoul la cité des bosquets un ghetto de
32 nationalités 30% de la population de
montfermeil habitent ici sur à peine 5 %
du territoire communal pour le maire
c'est un kyste nuisible à l'image de la
cité en ligne pour les immigrés
eux-mêmes depuis son élection en 83 il
demande à l'office public des hlm de ne
plus installer d'émigrer au bosquet mais
en vain alors pour forcer la négociation
il interdit régulièrement aux enfants
d'immigrés
l'accès aux deux maternelle de la cité
les enseignants s'insurgent et parce
qu'outre avec l'accord de leur académie
par lettre le maire prévient les deux
directrices qui ne considère plus les
deux écoles comme services publics de la
ville à la limite il pourrait leur
couper les crédits l'utilisent comme
moyen de pression les enfants il les
prend en otage mais en réalité pourquoi
est-ce qu'ils ne s'arrange pas avec les
maires des communes avoisinantes qui
sont morts pour puisqu'il ferait partir
les enfants émigrés les répartir lui dit
monsieur le préfet je vous prends je
vous donne l'engagement que dès
l'instant où on aura pu signer l'accord
avec l'office départemental des hlm
le lendemain même jeu régulariser la
situation de tous les enfants dont je
connais la situation
problème au point mort le ministère de
l'éducation rappelle que chacun a droit
à l'enseignement public et qu'il
n'hésiterait pas à intervenir comme il a
déjà dû le faire à montfermeil
depuis 85 l'étranger le pc